PROFESSOR: The
logic of predicates
is a basic concept in
mathematical language
as well as being a
topic on its own.
In particular, I'm going to talk
now about the idea of the two
so-called quantifiers.
For all-- that's
the upside-down A.
And exists-- that's
the backward E.
So what's a predicate?
Basically, a predicate
is a proposition,
except it's got variables in it.
Here's an example.
P of x, y is the predicate
that depends on x and y.
And let's say it's defined
to be x plus 2 equals y.
Now, in order to figure
out whether or not
a predicate is
true, I need to know
the values of the variables--
in this case, x and y.
So if I tell you that x is 1
and that y is 3, guess what?
P of 1 and 3-- P of x and
y when x is 1 and y is 3--
is true, because in fact,
1 plus 2 is equal to 3.
If I tell you that x is 1 and
y is 4, then since 1 plus 2
is not equal to 4, P
of 1 and 4 is false.
On the other hand, since
P of 1 and 4 is false,
that makes not P
of 1 and 1 true.
That's the easy part.
Now the quantifiers are read
as "for all" and "exists."
But they control a variable.
So I write "for all
x," it means-- sorry.
I write upside-down Ax and
I read it as "for all x."
I'm so used to reading it
that I forgot that I needed
to read symbols literally.
And backwards Ey is read
as "there exists some y."
So let's see how
that would work.
The upside-down A, for
all, acts like an AND.
To understand what it means,
let's look at this example.
Let's let a variable s range
over the staff members in 6.042
at this term, of whom there are
about 30 counting the graders.
Let's define a predicate
that depends on the variable
s called P of s that says
that s is pumped about 6.2042.
They're enthusiastic
about being on the staff.
OK.
If I tell you for
all s, P of s, that's
exactly the same as saying
that P of Drew is true,
and P of Peter is true,
and P of Keshav is true,
and a whole bunch more
ANDs down to P of Michaela.
They'll be 29 ANDs if
there are 30 staff members.
Similarly, the backwards E--
there exists-- acts like an OR.
If I tell you that t is now
ranging over the 6.042 staff
just as s was, and I write
B of t, the predicate of t
means the staff member
t took 6.042 before,
then if I tell you that there
exists a t B of t, what I'm
telling you is that B of Drew--
either Drew took it before,
or Peter took it before,
or Deshav took it before,
or Michaela took it before.
This statement is
true, because in fact,
several of the staff members
took 6.042 from me before.
And I'd like to think that the
previous one-- that everybody's
pumped up on the staff--
is true, although I
can't guarantee that.
So let's do a little practice
with existential quantifiers.
So let's agree that
the variables x and y
will range, for this example,
over the non-negative integers.
And let's consider the
following predicates
about y that says that there's
some x that's less than y.
Q of y is there exists an
x that x is less than y.
Let's see what happens.
Well, what about Q of 3?
Q of 3 is saying that
there is an x such
that x is less than 3.
Well, an example
of such an x is 1.
So that means there is
an x that's less than 3,
because 1 is.
And so that makes this Q true.
All right, what about Q of 1?
Well, again, there's an x that's
a non-negative integer, namely
0, that's less than 1.
And therefore, Q of 1 is true.
On the other hand,
Q of 0 is false
because there is no non-negative
integer that's less than 0.
And so there's no
value that you can
assign to x that's a
non-negative integer that
will make it less than 0.
OK, that one's not
so bad, I hope.
Let's look at the same example
with the universal quantifier.
This time, we'll say that R
of y means that for every x,
x is less than y.
Well, R of 1 is false.
And the reason is that
5 is a counterexample.
5 is not less than 1.
And so it's not true that
every x is less than 1.
R of 8 is false because
12 is not less than 8.
And therefore, not
every x is less than 8.
R of a googol, 10 to
the 100th, is false.
Because if you
let x be a googol,
it's not less than a googol.
And so it's an example of the
fact that this doesn't hold
for all x's.
That part's obvious.
OK.
The thing that tends to
confuse people in the beginning
is what happens when you
start mixing up quantifiers.
So let's look at an
intuitive example
first that might
help you remember
what happens when you have
an A followed by an E.
And then we'll look at
an E followed by an A.
So suppose I look
at this statement.
This time, I'm going
to tell you that v
ranges over the possible
computer viruses, not
biological viruses.
d ranges over
antivirus software,
defenses against viruses.
And I want to look
at the predicate that
says for every virus,
there is a defense such
that d protects against
v. This defense is good
against that virus.
All right, so each virus,
I have a defense for.
So an example would be-- these
are, by the way, dated viruses,
but that's when the
slides were made.
So against the Mydoom
virus, you could use
Defender, Microsoft Defender.
Against the ILOVEYOU virus,
you could use Norton.
Against the Bablas virus,
you could use ZoneAlarm.
Well, is that what we want?
It's expensive.
It means that for
every different virus,
I need a different defense.
I have to spend a
fortune on software.
This is not what we want.
So that's when for every
virus, there's a defense,
but the quantifiers
are in the wrong order.
Let's reverse them.
Suppose I tell you that
there's one defense that's
good for all viruses.
There is a defense such
that for every virus,
d protects against v. For
example, if d is MITviruscan,
then it would be
wonderful if it was true
that d protects
against all viruses,
there's one defense good
against every attack.
That's what we want
because it's a lot cheaper.
All right, let's start looking
at a concrete mathematical
example.
And I hope that that
prelude with the viruses
will help you decipher how
the quantifiers behave.
So let's look at
this predicate now.
Sorry, this is a proposition.
It really doesn't depend
on the values of x and y.
It's asking about all possible
x's and all possible y's,
whether there is one.
In order to figure out whether
a proposition like G is true,
actually, I do need to know
what x and y are ranging over.
Because as you'll see, whether
or not G comes out to be true
will depend on that.
So I'm going to look at
the domain of discourse
that x and y range over.
And we'll suppose
that the domain
is the non-negative integers.
So now, what G is saying
is that if you give me
a non-negative integer x, there
is a y that's greater than x.
In other words, I can find
another non-negative integer
that's bigger than x.
Well, that's certainly true.
There's a simple
recipe for finding y.
Give me an x.
Let's choose y to be
x plus 1, or x plus 2.
But I don't necessarily
need a recipe
as long as somewhere
out there, there's
a y that's bigger than x.
This is true.
So G is true when the
domain of discourse
is the non-negative integers.
On the other hand, when I
change the domain of discourse,
different things can happen.
So let's look at the negative
integers, the integers less
than 0, and ask, is it
true that for every x,
there's a y that's
greater than x?
Well, for a lot
of them, there is.
If x is minus 3, then
minus 2 is bigger than x.
If x is minus 2, then
minus 1 is bigger than x.
But then I'm in trouble.
If x is minus 1, there's
no negative integer
that's bigger than x.
And so G is false when
the domain of discourse
is the negative integers.
Well, let's shift again,
the point being here
both we're looking at
alternate quantifiers,
and we're understanding
that the truth
of a proposition with
quantifies depends crucially
on the domain of discourse.
If we let the
domain of discourse
be the negative reals,
then what this is saying
is that for every negative real,
there's a bigger negative real.
And that, of course, is true.
Because if you give me a
negative real r, then r
over 2, because it's negative,
is actually bigger than r.
And it will not be positive
if r isn't positive.
So sure enough, G in
this case is true.
All right, let's
reverse the qualifiers
and see what happens.
It's worth thinking about.
So let's call H the assertion
that for every y-- sorry,
that there exists a y such that
for every x, x is less than y.
So intuitively,
what this is saying
is there's a biggest element.
Y is bigger than everything.
Well, if the domain is
the non-negative integers,
then H is false because
there's no biggest
non-negative integer.
If it's the negative
integers, it's
false because there's no
biggest negative integer.
If it's the negative
reals, it's false
because there's no
biggest negative real.
But the truth is
that this thing is
going to be false in any
domain of discourse in which
less than is
behaving as it should
because all any y is not going
to be bigger than itself.
So you can't possibly
find a biggest y.
It would have to be
bigger than itself.
This is going to be false in
all of the sensible domains
where less than behaves
as we would expect.
So let's make this
slightly more interesting
and make that less
than or equal to.
So now, it's actually
possible that there
could be a biggest
element that is
greater than or equal to
everything including itself.
And if you look
at these domains,
well, there this isn't any
greatest non-negative integer,
because for any x,
plus 1 is bigger.
There isn't any biggest
negative real-- same reasoning.
For any r, r/2 is
going to be bigger.
But for the negative
integers, there
is a biggest y, namely minus 1.
It's greater than or equal to
every other negative integer.